so with Daredevil season 2 coming out
this week what I wanted to do here is
have a discussion on Electra and what
I'm hoping is that at the end of this
video you'll have a strong understanding
of her character as well as why she was
created to be a part of the Daredevil
line of
stories so for those of you who have not
seen my video on Daredevil explained
which you'll find in the description we
had talked about how his character had
gained a significant amount of
popularity following his introduction by
Stan Lee and Bill Everett in
1964 where some of this has been due to
the fact that he was created as a blind
hero with a hand censes due to exposure
to radioactive material this popularity
was shortlived in that with Jerry Conway
taking over the title with issue number
72 in 1971 instead of continuing the
themes established by the Daredevil
series he instead moved the Publications
over to a Pulp Fiction format
reminiscent of the pre and post Golden
Age Superman pop Comics focusing largely
on science fiction this combined with
Conway also moving Daredevil over to San
Francisco had largely alienated the
existing Daredevil fan base who had
grown accustomed to seeing Matt Murdoch
operate as a borderline antier hero in
Hell's Kitchen New York facing some of
Marvel's sediest enemies furthermore in
the face of fan reaction to Jerry
Conway's writing between the conclusion
of Conway's run with issue number 98 in
1971 running up until issue number 142
in 1975 Marvel had brought a series of
writers on board including Steve Gerber
and Tony Isabella both of whom were
unable to bring interest back to the
series where the title was handed over
to writer Marv Wolfman with issue number
143 in 1977 because both he and Len wine
were serving as editors following the
promotion of Roy Thomas editor and chief
with the workload being too much to
handle Wolfman stepped down as editor
and decreased his workload as writer
leading to a departure from the
Daredevil title after 20 issues where he
shifted his Focus to developing
Spiderwoman Jessica Drew Amazing
Spider-Man Fantastic Four and Doctor
Strange to this end the title continued
to see another slump in sales and a
series of writers with short stance in
the form of Jim shooter who wrote for
nine issues and Robert Mackenzie who
wrote for 16 both of whom were unable to
recapture the anti-hero element of
Daredevil's character due largely to the
fact fact that those readers who were
looking for anti-heroes founded in the
creation of the Punisher in 1974 by
Jerry Conway and John RZ Senor however
partway through MacKenzie's run on the
title Frank Miller had been brought on
board as a young artist looking to make
his bones in the industry because
Daredevil wasn't really considered a top
tier title at the time in Marvel Comics
despite having been around for so long
Frank Miller was partnered with Robert
McKenzie to Ink the series but also
offer input on the direction of the
stories themselves for Mackenzie did
have complete control while the stories
he wrote didn't necessarily identify
with prospective fans the artwork of
Frank Miller did meaning that when
Mackenzie was removed from the Daredevil
Series in 1980 with issue number 166
under the direction of the new editor-in
Chief Jim shooter Frank Miller was
positioned as writer and artist of the
series however the problem face by
Miller was that between the writing of
Jerry Conway Steve Gerber Jim shooter
Tony Isabella and Robert McKenzie the
Daredevil line was on the verge of
cancellation meaning that he may very
well have been put in charge of a title
destined for The Chopping Block using
this to his Advantage when he was
granted the the position of writer by
Jim shoter Miller also leveraged
complete control with the authority to
take the title in whatever Direction he
deemed appropriate and so with this new
found authority over the title Frank
Miller engineered a wholesale reboot of
the Daredevil line eliminating
characters he didn't like keeping the
characters he did inventing new
characters and retelling origin stories
all while completely ignoring virtually
all past continuity of the character
while this did anger some of the reader
base who would enjoy the stories of
Mackenzie and Wolfman the argument of
Miller was that in order for dared devil
to succeed he needed to be a character
like The Punisher whose morality was
known but often times questionable where
Miller went on to reboot Daredevil's
origin and change his father Jack
Murdoch from a kindly man to an abusive
alcoholic Miller also sought to replace
Daredevil's Rogues Gallery with a base
of villains who were darker and more
Sinister with more ambiguous motives
hailing from all corners of the globe by
way of Matt Murdoch's own past making
her debut with Daredevil issue number
168 1981 the appearance of Electra
initially came without a backstory
Beyond her first encounter with Matt
Murdoch
what we're told is that with Daredevil
pursuing a villain named alri
wallenquist in the midst of
interrogating a man by the name of Turk
the efforts of Daredevil to gain the
information he needs are interrupted by
the appearance of Electra in addition to
this because Daredevil's interrogation
of Turk was cut short by a man named
Bill who caused an explosion which
appeared to kill Turk the impact of the
blast had temporarily rattled mat
Murdoch's senses meaning he could still
detect BGE and question him on why he
killed Turk but was unaware of electr
lurking in the background making her
move and taking d by surprise where Bill
is able to make his Escape alectra
reveals that there's actually a boundy
on Walling quest which he intended to
collect now because this story was
designed to introduce us to Electra and
explain her relationship to Matt with
Daredevil being overcome by her assault
and blacking out Miller takes a time to
provide a flashback and what he tells us
is that during his time at Columbia
University alongside foggy Nelson the
two had stumbled into Electra who looked
to enroll as a new student but was also
being escorted around the campus by the
University president and her bodyguard
we're several days p pass following the
incident Matt Murdoch has foggy Nelson
provided distraction by throwing a paper
airplane in front of Electra and her
bodyguard investigating the source and
leaving Electra behind Matt makes his
appearance known by offering Electra a
rose now the significance of this is
that Miller establishes two main ideas
that I'd like you to keep in the back of
your head the first is that Electra is
of Greek descent and her father is a man
involved in the criminal underworld and
the second is that this leads into how
Electra became an enemy of Matt where
Matt offers to take Electra on a date
the issue of his blindness arises when
she declines the offer for fear of the
situation seeming awkward however
because Matt views her in such a way
instead of allowing her to escape he
pursues further and even goes so far as
to explain how he lost his sight in the
first place now whether alector chooses
to go on a date with Matt for his
bravery and pushing an old man out of
danger and being hit with radioactive
material or because he states that he's
never told anyone that story before is
not revealed here and in truth Frank
Miller didn't want it to be the reason
why is that when Miller took over the
Daredevil title his goal was was to make
both Matt Murdoch and his supporting
characters more believable meaning that
instead of answering every single
question that we as the reader had on
multiple occasions Miller would simply
leave it up to us to develop our own
answers and so while we would never see
this date occur what we're told is that
over the course of the next several
weeks the two Fall in Love Leading to a
very passionate relationship that lasts
around one year however while preparing
to get together with Electra and
celebrate her birthday when both Matt
and foggy arrive at her dorm room they
realize a gathering has emerged in light
of the building being surrounded by by a
police barricade taking to a rooftop and
using his senses to listen in on the
situation Miller reveals that Electra
and her father have been held hostage by
a group of criminals who are currently
negotiating with the police now
something I'd like you to take notice of
here is that even if it's only in bits
and pieces Miller uses this flashback to
explain some of Murdoch's abilities
including his cunning his ability to
LEAP distances Beyond those of normal
humans and even his agility in
negotiating the various terrains and
obstacles he faces and pursuing foes now
where Daredevil is able to sneak into
the building and begin taking out
criminals his actions also come with a
valuable lesson and that while he can
control himself and does possess
enhanced senses he cannot account for
the actions of others now this is an
extremely important part of his
character and went towards developing
the nature of Daredevil as a hero by the
way in which he learns this lesson comes
when he overpowers the criminals and
sends one of them out of the window
because the police officers below are
unable to differentiate between who was
an enemy and who was a hostage their
belief is that the criminals are killing
the hostages after which they fire on
the building
killing Electra's father in the process
as a result and after an unknown amount
of time alectra eventually leaves Matt
Murdoch after having become disillusion
with the laws of the United States and
that the police aren't prosecuted for
the murder of her father as well as the
idea that people in the world are
inherently evil now where Daredevil
comes to after this flashback Miller
also establishes that between the time
she left and her sudden appearance in
Hell's Kitchen Murdoch did not know
anything about what had happened to
Electra and while he would normally look
into the possibility of rekindling the
former relationship ship between the two
in the end as a hero his role is to keep
her from killing wallenquist and bring
her to justice for her actions as a
bounty hunter from here we transition to
another part of Hill's kitchen and pick
up with wallenquist himself and a man
named Eric Slaughter now Eric Slaughter
is actually not a new creation in the
story and first appeared with Daredevil
issue number
159 as he was created by Robert McKenzie
Eric Slaughter was a Crime Boss who used
his wealth to hire various criminals in
an attempt to kill Daredevil while he
was occasionally hired by other
individuals like Bullseye overall
Slaughter rarely acted on his own and
used henchmen to achieve his goals in
this instance Slaughter has been hired
by wallenquist who has committed a
series of unknown crimes in Europe but
also witnessed a murder making him the
key component to a trial as a result
wallenquist is being pursued by Electra
who looks to collect the Bounty for his
European crimes as well as Daredevil who
looks to keep him alive so he can offer
testimony at the trial and so where
Slaughter receives a call from BGE
informing him that everything's been set
up to get wallenquist out of the country
Al live it's revealed that this phone
call is being made under the threat of
electric killing BGE in order to draw
wallenquist out into the open following
this where Bill had stated that the SE
plane would be ready at around 4:00 a.m.
Because the actual time was 3:00 a.m.
Slaughter reveals that the statement was
meant to indicate whether or not bu and
been captured by Electra and that by
providing the incorrect time Slaughter's
been made aware of Electra's actions
allowing him to stay one step ahead
taking the opportunity to also send one
of his henchmen to a local cigar store
in order to resupply his stash of cigars
de devil seizes the opportunity to
kidnap the henchman after realizing that
if billage was involved so was Slaughter
and that it was only a matter of time
before he sent someone to fetch cigars
now something I'd also like you to
notice here is how Daredevil
interrogates Mickey while Daredevil
threatens to kill him he doesn't really
act on it so much as he uses the
experience to terrorize Mickey the
reason why I brought this up is that
prior to Frank Miller's run Daredevil
didn't really threaten people with death
where he would hang them from buildings
and scare them a bit the mention of
killing them went towards the darker
element of Daredevil who was more akin
to Batman of the 1970s and his
willingness to push the limits to
achieve his goal and so transitioning to
the Westside Waterfront at around 4:00
a.m. we pick up with Slaughter and his
henchmen encountering Electra with the
intention of taking her prisoner however
because our expertise in martial arts
predates her college Years with Matt
Murdoch her formidable skill set allows
her to easily overpower Slaughters men
something to also take note of here is
that while Miller doesn't explain it in
any kind of backstory with Electra being
offered a position in Slaughter's
organization she turns it down under the
idea that she doesn't serve any cause
law or man now the reason why this
matters is that with the death of her
father leaving her dissolution with laws
and Society her role as a bounty hunter
fulfills her desire for Revenge but also
allows her to deliver Justice according
to her own moral compass and outside the
context of laws of society which she may
or may not view as being adequate now
I'd like you to keep this in the back of
your mind and the reason why is because
as we continue through this video and
especially once we jump into the
Daredevil Netflix series proper this
particular bit will basically Bally
established that Electra is not a
traditional villain in the form of
someone like Kingpin instead she's more
of a blend between Punisher and
Daredevil and that Murdoch upholds the
color of law bringing criminals to
Justice in the courts and Frank Castle
simply kills criminals without remorse
Electra on the other hand uses her own
moral code to decide which contract she
takes and only takes those contracts
that she deems to be worthy and so with
Daredevil arriving but finding Electra
held at gunpoint by wallenquist with
Matt being instructed to walk away he
also realizes that W Quist will shoot
him in the back as soon as he's far
enough using a senses to detect
wallenquist movements at the moment
before he fires Daredevil disarms
wenquist by shouting hit him low olive
oil now because this is the same phrase
that he had shouted when he and Alexa
were fighting the criminals in her dorm
room aler comes to the realization that
Matt Murdoch is Daredevil but because
she leads a criminal life and Daredevil
leads the life of a hero it's
essentially impossible for the two of
them to mend the rift meaning that
whenever she appears in Hell's Kitchen
under normal circumstances Daredevil
will almost always be there to stop her
now following her initial appearance and
going forward into the Daredevil series
Electra became one of the most important
women in Marvel alongside Jean Gray
storm Carol daners and Emma Frost the
reason for this is that where genan gray
represented the evolution of women from
background characters to prominence
storm represented Independence Carol
dver represented success and Emma Frost
represented Ingenuity Electra
represented all of these things as a
character who followed her own path and
refused to be pinned down to any one
ideology or employer Electra was a
reflection of the very essence of
feminist ideals depicting a strong
independent woman who could endure
virtually any situation on her own while
this did draw the attention of women
particularly young girls it also drew
the attention of a lot of younger men
the reason for this came and the
sexuality of Electra in terms of how she
was depicted but also because of the
history of Daredevil Comics themselves
what I mean here is that where Daredevil
had multiple love interests the most
notable being Caren Paige who was a
character that debuted in issue number
one and was revamped by Frank Miller to
be a heroin addict and a pornographic
actress there had never really been an
instance where Murdoch had fallen in
love with a woman who would go on to
become his opposite in terms of their
moral compass and equal regarding their
fighting prowess this combined with the
fact that Electra created an internal
struggle for Murdoch and that he still
harbored feelings for which towards the
idea of creating stories with whicher
character development that focus on
having Electra and Daredevil serve as
both allies and enemies as an example
with issue number 174 1981 titled the
assassination of Matt Murdoch Frank
Miller introduced the mystical ninja
organization known as the hand who had
also been hired to kill Daredevil coming
together alongside Melvin Potter a
martial artist operating under the name
Gladiator the involvement of electure
came and that she had overheard members
of the hand plotting to kill Daredevil
while she didn't intend to become
involved her love for Matt ultimately
drove her to Hell's Kitchen where she
warned Matt Murdoch of the coming
assassination attempt which allowed him
to defeat the hand however in issue
number 179 title somebody had to win
Electra became the chief Assassin of
Kingpin where she was tasked with
killing reporter Ben urick due to his
investigative journalism coming close to
uncovering the criminal activities of
Wilson Fisk while her appearances in the
Daredevil line of stories under Frank
Miller only lasted a handful of issues
her popularity as an on again off again
Ally of Daredevil coupled with the
Romantic tension between the two
elevated her to one of Daredevil's most
popular supporting characters with some
fans arguing that she was just as
popular as Matt Murdoch himself now
having said all of that while I haven't
been able to find a reason as to why
Frank Miller killed her off I had a
conversation with s over at Comic pop
and we came to the conclusion that with
Frank Miller looking to evolve the
character of Daredevil and revolving his
life around dark and tragic
circumstances it made sense to kill off
Electra who fans viewed as a potential
love interest of Daredevil but also
provide a circumstance wherein his
character could be expanded on further
regarding how he coped with the loss of
an individual he had known for so long
and viewed as both an enemy and a friend
coming out of issue number 179 which
ended with Electra being defeated by
Daredevil following her attempts to kill
benu were her actions in terrorizing UR
drove the Daily Bugle to abandon their
segment on investigating Kingpin because
Daredevil had interfered Kingpin sent
Electra to kill foggy Nelson as an
intimidation tactic to keep Matt Murdoch
away while Electra had intended to go
through with the assassination after
being informed by foggy that he
recognizes her as one of Daredevil's
ex-girlfriends from college for reasons
unexplained alectra simply abandons the
assignment allowing foggy to leave
following this because Wy had been
looking to take Electra's position as
kingpin's assassin he takes the
opportunity to capitalize on her M AR
weakness which culminates in Bullseye
stabbing her through the chest with one
of her own weapons as a result while
Electra didn't die immediately after
making her way to Murdock's home and
dying in his arms a battle ensued
between Murdoch and Bullseye leading to
Daredevil dropping Bullseye from a power
line almost killing him in the process
now while Frank Miller would resurrect
Electra and then remove her from the
Daredevil title in the two-part story
Siege and Resurrection in truth I don't
really have an answer as to why this was
done when Electra had died in issue
number 181 Miller had undertaken the
step necessary to begin making Murdoch
darker with issue number 184 titled No
More Mr nce guy during his fight with
the Punisher and issue number 187 in a
conversation he had with black widow but
regardless of his motives at the
conclusion of issue number 190 Frank
Miller established that electure would
never return to the Marvel landscape
however in 1993 underwriter DG
Chichester and editor-in-chief Tom
defala the decision was made to return
her to the comic book landscape with a
five-part story fall from grace serving
as a way to reinvent the Daredevil
character by having Matt Murdoch take on
a new name of Jack battlin after his
father Dawn a new armor costume and
fashion new weapons for himself the
return of electri came in the form of a
redcon to explain why her character had
appeared in allh at the end of Daredevil
issue number 190 what we're told is that
when she had been resurrected her
Essence had split into two separate
beings one which was Pure Evil and one
which was pure good designed to reflect
the dichotomy between her heroic and
anti-heroic self at the conclusion of
the story alexer had destroyed the
physical body of her evil half restoring
it unto herself and officially returning
to the Marvel landscape following this
in order to ensure that existing fans of
the Daredevil series had a better
understanding of her character in 1995
Chai Chester returned to write the
four-part series Electra root of evil
which looked to use the information
provided over the course of Electra's
run in the main Daredevil series as well
as her miniseries by Frank Miller and
provide a more accessible story for both
new and existing fans told in a series
of flashbacks between the present day
and the past chai chest reveals at a 12
years old a lecture had been inducted
into the cast an order of martial artist
similar to the hand but led by stick the
former mentor of Daredevil who
occasionally operates as both Ally and
villain to Matt Murdoch during her time
under sticks tutelage Electra's days
were spent in the icy terrain of the
cast order in an unknown location where
she was trained in the art of survival
self-defense and mysticism during the
story Chai Chester also established that
Electra's mother had been killed by
areses the enigmatic brother of Electra
who had only appeared around seven times
in Marvel Comics where her mother was
gone down due to her extramarital
Affairs Electra survived and was born
prematurely during which time she was
raised in the wealthy life of her
father's criminal Empire until she was
attacked by kidnappers at 9 years old
after which her father determined she
needed a martial arts master with a
story jumping forward to electure at 19
years old Chai Chester maintains the
original death of her father in
Daredevil issue number 168 are providing
an updated version of Hugo's death at
the hands of the police during a botch
kidnapping while the rest of the origin
would go on to connect with her
encounter with Matt Murdoch following
this four issue Series in addition to
making appearances within the Daredevil
series proper her character also became
a part of the overarching Marvel lineup
including wol rain the Enemy of the
State story line where Logan was
brainwashed and began attacking enemies
of the hand and Hydra as well as Frank
Miller's five-part miniseries Daredevil
The Man Without Fear which Revisited and
expanded on the history of Electra by
exploring her early days of her
relationship with Daredevil while some
of these stories would involve her
acting as an agent of shield under Nick
Fury and others would see her teaming up
with Spider-Man as a character that had
been such an integral part of
Daredevil's history and extremely
popular among new readers who look to
understand why older fans wanted her to
return the success of Electra led to a
solo Series in 1996 and 2001 written by
Peter Milligan and Brian Michael Bennis
respectively both of whom use the
stories to explain how Alexa viewed the
world prior to her Murder By Bullseye
and her Resurrection by the hand while
each has been considered landmark in
their own right with Milligan's run
focusing heavily on electri coming to
grips with her life following her murder
and Resurrection
as well as benness providing a more
updated series to reflect the modern
reader at the conclusion of bis's run in
2004 going into the launch of House of M
like many of Marvel's popular heroes and
villains Electra was revamped within the
pages of the tyin comic House of M
Avengers number three where stre was
revealed to be an agent of the Kingpin
but was defeated by Iron Fist Danny Rand
following this and with Marvel launching
Civil War Electra actually didn't make
any appearances in the Civil War event
itself and the reason for this was
revealed in the post Civil War Story
titled secret invasion when it was
revealed that prior to the house of IM
aent the shape-shifting Scrolls had been
secretly replacing humans and
superpowered beings alike with scroll
Replacements following their planet's
destruction by galatis where the scroll
threat was first discovered by Nick Fury
during his time Underground following
the fury secret War storyline the heroes
of Earth becoming aware of the scr
threat came when Electra was revealed to
be one of the aliens following her death
while the conclusion of secret Invasion
would see Tony starkk deposed Shield
disbanded and replaced with the agency
Hammer led by Norman Osborne aside from
a few appearances in red where she
fought alongside Deadpool of Punisher
and others and attempting to kill the
mercenary Domino as well as a 2010
Shadowland story which saw Daredevil
building the Shadowland prison in Hell's
Kitchen New York drawing the attention
of Spider-Man Luke Cage Iron Fist and
others against him in truth Electra
didn't actually see much attention in
the way of Marvel while some attribute
this to the idea that her popularity had
run its course While others believed
that Marvel didn't really have a strong
place to put her in 2013 and 2014 during
the events leading up to the launch of
Secret Wars underwriter Daniel away Al
lecture was rolled over into the
Thunderbolts alongside the Punisher
Deadpool Venom and red Hulk operating as
a Strike Team under the direction of Red
Hulk himself while the series only
lasted 32 issues the combination of
these characters as a team drew the
attention of multiple readers due to its
strange makeup and so using this
popularity as a platform in 2014 debut
writer W Haden Blackman launched the
third Electra solo series with a
five-part story Bloodlines looking to
the history of her character for many
Blackman's run was considered extremely
well written due to Blackman taking the
stance that various writers had tried
too hard to recapture the legacy of
Electra instead of living up to what it
was that made her popular to this end
instead of writing a series of wildly
convoluted stories and team ups instead
Blackman took Electra's character back
to what it was that made her great in
the eyes of fans in the first place
being an assassin for hire and so with
the title had its ups and downs lasting
around 11 issues after which it was
canceled at the start of Secret Wars for
individuals who were looking to receive
a complete understanding of her
character ranging from her younger days
stretching up through her experiences
dying and being resurrected as well as
finding her place in the world the
Blackman run is usually pointed to the
very definition of the place to start
for those individuals who are looking to
get into the electric
character with that being said we're
going to go ahead and bring this video
to an end and make sure you post a
comment down below and let me know what
you think about Electra and I will catch
you guys later
peace